oh I med Crawley the president of the
skulk of Institute of Science and
Technology in Moscow and you may have
noticed I'm not a Russian I'm talking
today about the credit and in response
to the question by Ellen winters on
facebook please tell me what you care
about and future directions you'd like
to see in the world so my job now is to
create in the Russian Federation a new
institution centered around science
technology and innovation and that's
what I care about in the world I care
about trying to take scientific
discoveries and work with bright young
students and faculty members to produce
goods and services that will make life
interesting life better health better
and will be developed contribute to the
sustainable development of our nation's
I've chosen to do this in the Russian
Federation because I was asked I there's
a wonderful new program in russia called
Skolkovo which is a whole new attempt to
build an intense region of economic
development that will incorporate
startups large companies and a
university based on technology try this
might come to skolka but get involved in
building things that really help people